[Music]
foreign
Lauren she just walked through the door
we had Colton jumping over a fence just
jumped that's Chris Harrison opening up
n and the darkness it's time for roses
and rosy hi everybody
you guys i'm lauren zima i don't even
know what episode this is a folding
under what season of The Bachelor the
number the day the week the month bottom
line he jumped the fence he jumped the
fence he jumped the fence oh and now we
know what was on the other side and
we're gonna get through it all but first
of all we're gonna give it a build up
just like they did on the episode and
the build up is a date with Taoiseach oh
sorry girl okay we needed a full glass
of wine for this and I just want to know
overall you guys first question of the
night where was your stress factor with
the fence jump how emotional were you
scale of one glass of wine to ten
please drink responsibly okay so things
start out with I am so stressed out I
couldn't print my notes so I'm gonna go
off my phone the screens gonna lock a
bunch and like just power through with
me okay I have a face idea it'll be
quick
yeah I'm lucky my phone I'm being weird
you're gonna need to get some really
surprisingly accurate thought technology
freaks me out anyway what you want to
chat about you know I know less last
time I had a little awkward conversation
with you and I don't want to make this
one be awkward Becca fantasy suite
conversation so Chris and Colton are
talking and we're all hoping this talk
won't be as awkward as it was on Becca
season between Chris and Colton I guess
I just want to know sort of what the
expectations are are you saying you're
worried about being intimate with Becca
at this point yeah and you know what
Colton says quote I think the moment you
start planning things out that's you're
doing yourself a disservice and I have
to say disagree Colton maybe if you'd
planned things a little more you
wouldn't be a virgin at this point then
again I guess she wanted me so whatever
I'm waiting for an opportunity
Colton says he wants to make love with
somebody who I'm in love with who he
loves and who's in love with him in love
with me but don't drink every time
Colton says laughs I feel like I'm in
love
Bigelow but I am in love with who's in
love with me I got a lot to get through
luckily I didn't drive here was dropped
off that's called planning ahead okay
2-out gone wrong and we are going to
portugal I've never been I want to go do
you want to go to Portugal what location
do you want to see on the show that
haven't been on the show yet I don't
think I should ask this question we only
care about the fence jump right who
cares where we are there's a fence great
wherever it is there's a fence great
okay
building trust then we get some relief
and I quote myself boring recaps of the
final three we've been with you this
whole time we know who you are
well tisha and Cassie we know who you
are energy we don't know what ton about
you really we know you beatbox sitting
right here with people I love the most
whatever we didn't even need the recaps
cuz the beatboxing wasn't in her recap
and that was her most important Robin
recaps what's that okay then
tisha and Colton and they are in
Portugal I think honestly it kind of
looked like they were at like a high
school and then tation Colton get in a
helicopter and drink everytime tasia has
an over-the-top reaction to getting in a
helicopter it's like at this point you
bungee jumped you skydive which put you
in a plane are you really not excited
about a helicopter and also like I don't
know ala copter just seemed so late in
the season to be getting a helicopter
again and can these two just ever keep
their feet on the ground can you be on
the ground get grounded I don't believe
your relationship because it's not
grounded it's all in the air
this is metaphorical but also like
literally truth okay and then you know I
just wrote down imagine if Taoiseach and
Colton were giving you a tour of Fleur
Portugal
[Music]
drink every time they say something
totally nonsensical in this helicopter
[Music]
anyway I won't be taking that tour and
then they land and called Natasha sit on
a blanket at the edge of a mountain keep
your feet on the ground after all of the
death-defying experiences these two have
had together like are they just trying
to die at this point do they just have a
death wish back the blanket up I mean
they were on the edge drinking I'm
drinking on a couch in a studio not on a
cliff I'm not stupid I'm putting myself
up for I've asked him for some jokes
there hmm
Thanks playing another country being
high the sky but you know what a good
toast from Taoiseach and I sort of feel
like I have to highlight each good toast
this season because hanabi's toast was
so horrible if the givers come here
someone give a toast I'm like good job
you got out words in a sentence good job
good toast
excellent toast to sitting at the edge
of the world no you get away from the
edge everything's about to fall over the
edge you're not okay then they're eating
their dinner it's fantasy suites dinner
and like you know Brooklyn's a virgin
which I'd sort of forgotten again cuz
I'm like wrapped up another crap at this
point this season but like he's a virgin
and like T she's like my boobs popping
out yes your boob no it's not supposed
to there's tape I was just like this is
like the most awkward I just feel like
I'm like being teased like it's like
middle schoolers like oh you're your
nipple might pop out like I don't know I
just want to adults to have sex if
they're gonna have sex you know I was I
was the biggest fear staying in there I
don't know it was weird cuz then there's
like they're going to the fantasy suite
like drums are sounding and the music's
really dramatic and then they get to the
hotel room and there's a bath that's
already drawn and I'm like how cool is
that bad think of
how was the path been sitting there I
don't want to get in that bath who drew
that bath no thank you
mmm nothing about it was sexy to me were
you guys feelin sexy vibes equipment
Asia like I just wasn't feeling it I was
one of those things like you just have
to have confidence that you're doing the
right thing
oh this wasn't interesting detail wasn't
it cold instead of sex and I quote I
mean how hard can be okay
and he also divulged quote without
getting into details course and done I
really like experienced anonymous I've
pretty much done everything I'm
experienced in other ways okay let's not
forget let's not forget that Colton on a
previous episode had said that he wanted
his first time to be whatever woman he
was with best time ever we've got lofty
goals here people dose to lofty goals
[Applause]
whoo we're not gonna get to those goals
because tation Colton don't have sex and
you know what tisha said they didn't
have sex and I appreciated that we knew
they didn't have sex like I like that
she just said it too directly quote her
she said I don't know when was last Anna
Colton spent at a time
so I could just pick up on how nervous
he was she said he was nervous they
didn't have the physical intimacy she
was looking for and I wrote down O'Day
mm-hmm I appreciate it though that they
just straight-up told us because a lot
of the time fantasy suites are question
mark right we don't know if the people
actually had sex or not they tease to it
like they wake up in the morning they
have a fruit plate there in robes
whatever but we don't always get an
answer in fact we often don't get an
answer and in this case he's a virgin so
like we kind of really needed but maybe
also is it too rude is it too intrusive
Mel so he's shared a soul story with us
like we need the answer and I started to
think about the order of the fantasy
suites and tell me if you guys were
thinking about this were you considering
who went first second or third the order
is always a weird thing to me because
it's like I don't know it's just weird
you know that everybody's hooking up and
it's just weird but in this case it's
all about whether Colton is going to
lose his virginity so if he had sex with
the very first fantasy suite person then
would he go to like two or three and be
like big news I'm not a virgin anymore
and then I don't know if it was me like
I'd go an interview Mona I'd be like how
was it how did it go did you learn
anything do you want to so okay cool so
you graduated high school now I'm moving
to college what's going on how'd it go
what happened how was it I'm I care
about you I'm your friend no no was it
good was it great was it bad and I would
ask a lot of questions it's quite a
conundrum that they have not been in
before you know literally like there's
never been a virgin lead before Sean
Lowe doesn't count he is a born-again
virgin there's never been a lead who had
never had sex before before don't drink
every time I say go for it do it
responsibly do it yeah that's what
someone should say Nicole
[Music]
anyway no I still feel great in the
relationship so then what we have
realized is that Colton is not into
Taoiseach didn't we see it did you guys
feel it did you get that vibe because he
said and I quote
should say that she loves me it's really
nice to hear that's like the thank you
response you know it's not good there's
not passion there there's not fire I
felt at this point tisha was gone to me
what did you guys think you know they
were like we're glad for the time blah
blah blah
Colton said and I quote my mind
automatically is still thinking about
the other two relationships
ah why do you squiffed Asia oh Taoiseach
see you later tasia oh right okay but
that was weird to me was and I got a
little frustrated with Colton said
hopefully those feelings for Taoiseach
do come at some point really excuse me
really really really is that what you're
hoping for why would you hope to fall
for somebody who you had not yet fallen
for at this point if you're already
falling for somebody else call it a day
on tape that's what I wrote down and I
mean that in a nice way
today I liked a but it's time to get out
of here Bay dr. Seuss is done okay now
on to the meat of the sandwich nobody
says that the Cathy Day
so now coolin saying he wants to be in
love with Cassie and I'm like cool mood
don't you want to be in love with why do
you want to fall in love with everybody
just pick somebody like we can say we
want to be in love but nobody should be
saying I want to be in love with her I
want to be in love with her I want to be
in love with her pick somebody that does
doesn't mean suspense of defense coming
forth hands grab a sixpence and buy a
ticket
I got a stop I'm sorry I don't know why
rhyming makes me so happy there's no
possibility that happiness night we can
be in love I hope we are I hope like we
can get there
don't drink every time Colton says he
hopes he falls in love like just are you
in love to be in love mm-hmm
I got the vibe that Colton was trying
for the sake of the show honestly to not
say what he really wanted to say and
guess what
I was in it again it doesn't happen
often
okay so : Cassie get into the date and
Colton start saying that he feels like
himself me or myself than ever
he feels complete when he's with Cassie
it's clear colons in love with Cassie
right right right and then he said
nothing more to hear that Cassie is
falling in love with me okay
don't you think golden loves Kathy at
this point yeah yeah yes okay but but
then things take a turn I just wish I
had more time because we'd start to your
Cassie's feelings and we have the
feeling that Colton's gonna get crushed
Colton sounds so naive he says she's
given me every reason to think
except telling you that she's falling
for you remember Cassie's the one person
who hasn't said that she's even falling
in love with Colton anyway for sure I
love Cassie
oh my god he loves her for me boy he
loves her he loves her and remember he
was thinking about Cassie when he
hesitates yet oh my god
and then Cassie says the cold makes her
feel comfortable and safe so really
comfortable and safe not good it's not
good you guys that's like being like I
feel comfortable with my brother
remember that date when the psychic guy
or whatever he was on that street said
that they were brothers and sisters in
the past life Oh God
I did ask him for a blessing at the end
of this if we get their print engagement
I didn't get his approval
Colton admits to Cassie and I was glad
that he told her that was the right
thing to do but her dad did not give him
the blessing to propose to her oh I'm so
confused right now and can I see is
somebody who I think is really close to
their family we can tell that because
she's really struck by this she starts
tearing up she's so confused oh my god
what are we gonna do well a van pulls up
in Portugal a tree falls in the forest a
fish swims in the sea a virgin tries to
have sex Cassie's dad shows up
yes he pulls up in the van and I just
want to applaud the producers I want to
applaud them I want to vigorously
applaud them I want to cheer for them
who thought of this a race for you
what a brilliant move bringing Cassie's
dad to Portugal
the man who unlike any other parents
I've ever seen on the show without
raising his voice without changing the
tone of his voice strikes fear into my
heart I'd love this man and he is there
to talk to his daughter about what he
thinks she should do and guess what she
gonna listen mm-hm
she has you know listen oh crap I lost
my notes I can't say that I was
convinced that she was in love so I want
to make sure that she's both eyes open
Cassie's dad straight-up tells her she
doesn't seem that into kolten plain and
simple and what am I the servant dad oh
my god I mean I don't know if my parents
would have been able to tell like when I
was into someone it's like almost a
little bit intense and intimate but also
like cool he's a cool dad no not a scary
dad you know give a blessing after half
our conversation with somebody isn't
really diligent and then he leaves very
quickly quick quick trip to Portugal for
dad I gotta look up how long the flight
from the LA area where they live is de
Portugal and I hope dad got a helicopter
tour or something while he was there and
I hope it was better than the one that
Colton Taoiseach got but quick trip and
meaningful trip because then we get the
dinner and oh man we hear Colton's say
quote I'm very excited for dinner but
I'm more excited for what comes after
dinner
and that's the over anything oh god oh
god I think he was thinking he was gonna
die so casting so now we're sensing the
buildup and we know the fence jump is
coming and Colton says Cassie is the one
dressed and he says you can see them
working out together forever and then
tell me if you guys got confused here
were you baffled by Cassie's actions at
the start of this date she seems so
happy go-lucky she was smiling she was
being chatty with Colt and then I was a
company doing well layabouts a dump
we know you talked to your dad earlier
we know that he flew here from LA in his
sweater but tell me what you thought of
Cassie's vibe it was a little weird to
me I was also confused by Cassie's
reasoning because she started to say you
know that like her parents never had
doubts well how long did her parents
date before they got married I would be
curious to know because her and Colton I
haven't gotten to date that long you
know so I didn't think that that was
fair and he was a tough conversation for
me to have with him
yeah I thought he would have liked
giving you know nothing about like left
it more like open-ended alright so then
we're in the throes of it Cassie is
slowly but surely dumping Colton and
then she called him sweet and oh my god
that was rough again is he her brother
from another mother we don't know and
then she tells him she loves him but
she's not in love with him and it love
you so much thanks so much I don't like
I'm not I'm not like in love
oh so hard how hard can it be difficult
tremendously difficult the breakup is
happening were you on the edge of your
seat were you reaching for your wine
tell me okay and then cooled and asked
Cassie if she was planning on leaving
tonight and she says yes I don't know if
I can get there
what golden is there we know that and
don't drink every time Cassie says she
doesn't know and she walks out and she's
pacing and Colton is just sitting there
and now she's second-guessing it and
don't drink every time someone needs to
be closed caption during this horrifying
breakup and Colton walks over as a
producer and then the producer walks
away goodbye producer and we are still
closed captioning the conversation and
then Colton tells Cassie he's okay with
being patient well Colton we know you've
been a virgin for 26 years he does have
patients we have to give him that you
know and Combe says it's not easy going
through early days for another woman
when all I do is think about you know my
god I feel like the whole season has
been a lie all the other relationships
were a lie right it's really
mind-boggling what did you guys think
how struck for you by that comment oh
and then Colton starts to tell her look
this is bigger than anything was going
on right now
meaning him and Cassie and he says you
don't have to get engaged at the end of
this meaning the show and I just felt
like this was such a raw real intense
moment you guys because Colton was like
kind of throwing the show to the side a
little bit and just saying like I really
care about you and I was captivated how
did you feel I'm looking at a camera
that's not there that's how captivated I
am I've lost my frickin mind in our
studio okay okay
our camera guys are laughing at me okay
so he says I care for you I love you I
want to be you at the end of this
engage we're gonna just drink for that
whole sentence and I wrote down this is
horrifying like here was my question how
much would you plead with that person at
this point how much would you beg
someone to stay with you when they
wanted to walk away because you start to
think if I keep begging like that
doesn't mean they're gonna stay in fact
it means upon we're likely to leave
because everybody wants that they can't
happen I want them and they don't want
me okay so and by the way guys we talk a
lot about how music amplifies the show
there is no music during this it is
painfully deliciously horrifyingly
tremendously silent
anyway cool news walking kasi on I don't
even know where there it's too dark just
like this moment and drink every time I
have to close caption them and they say
I love you to each other but it's like
it's such a friends way oh my it's like
how I love you babes like everyone I've
ever met and holding the heads up to the
stairs in this treehouse fantasy suite
and oh my god those stairs look familiar
we've seen footage of him pushing the
camera at the bottom of those stairs we
know what's coming Cassie is gone
what do you guys think very quickly do
you think the Cassie should have left
she seemed unsure on her decision but
was it the right decision or was she
influenced by her dad do you think she
has real feelings for Colton do you
think that she left too soon she seemed
a little torn about it did you believe
her let me know that was a lot of
questions I'm sorry
lots of tikkun okay and I'm just gonna
read out out what I wrote down here and
there it is then : is breaking stuff and
now he's gone into the night and he's
taking off his mic and we hear somebody
say somebody get Chris and Chris
Harrison is coming and saying Dalton
Colton and Chris clearly thinks cold is
going to stop at the fence but he says
after hook jumped over the fence he just
jumped the effing fence he just jumped
that's and there over the vents in
through the woods and oh my god is it
was it's too dark the fence doesn't open
this reminds me of the scene in
bridesmaids when Kristen Wiig is sitting
on top of the fence and she's stuck up
there that would have been funny if a
producer gotten stuck up there anyway
sign know but back to the main point it
is so dark and now it's the Blair Witch
Project and Chris Hedges dogs barking
down here there's dogs barking over
there and I guess maybe you went over
there because we know Clayton loves dogs
and there's all the producers and now
Chris Harrison is running oh my god have
we ever seen Chris Harrison right on
this show ever
and Colton is gone into the night just
like our hopes and dreams I can't I was
gonna try to drink all this minute camp
you guys I got I got nothing else cold
you guys couldn't jump the fence
this door closes really slowly kind of
anticlimactic
[Music]
Lauren
Lauren you just walk through the door
how do you open this door is there an
intern that can open the door
ta my driver my dog walker I did one-oh
give her a wine bottle opening over here
one I gotta break into a run
bounder
[Music]
you